eeuu anunció sanciones contra altos
mandos de la policía cubana por su papel
en la represión de las protestas del 11
de julio el presidente joe biden
advirtió que si no hay cambios drásticos
llegarán nuevas sanciones
crisis migratoria en la frontera entre
colombia y panamá en el municipio de
necoclí miles de personas acampan hace
días mientras se esperan seguir viaje
hacia eeuu y france 24 viajó a la zona y
les traemos toda la información
los mexicanos irán a las urnas el 1º de
agosto para participar en una consulta
popular en la que elegirán si se deben
esclarecer decisiones tomadas por ex
presidentes del país para garantizar
justicia a las víctimas la medida de
cierta polémica entre los ciudadanos
hola muy buenas noches bienvenidos una
vez más a las noticias de france en 24
mi nombre es santiago ariztía y
comenzamos esta emisión en eeuu donde el
presidente joe biden calificó como
intolerable la situación que se vive en
cuba y advirtió que si no cambia de
manera drástica llegarán más sanciones a
la isla además de la que ya fueron
impuestas hoy mismo a la policía cubana
subdirector y subdirector por su papel
en la represión a las protestas del
pasado 11 de julio el mandatario
estadounidense afirmó además que
ayudarán a que mejore el servicio de
internet en el país aunque no especificó
cómo lo harán esto tras haber mantenido
una reunión con cubanoestadounidenses en
la casa blanca- un encuentro que el
canciller de cuba bruno rodríguez
calificó como una farsa desde twitter el
funcionario cubano señaló además que
eeuu sólo le interesa a la maquinaria
electoral de florida
la reunión del presidente bailen con
anexionistas cubanos es una farsa para
justificar operación de cambio de
régimen versus cuba al gobierno de eeuu
sólo le interesa maquinaria electoral
florida mientras ignora reclamo del
pueblo cubano de sus electores cubanos y
estadounidenses y del mundo y
precisamente cuba recibió este viernes
dos cargas de ayuda humanitaria que
fueron enviadas por los gobiernos de
méxico y de bolivia para ayudar a hacer
frente al desabastecimiento de productos
básicos que padece la isla en medio del
peor rebrote de kobe 19 un buque de la
armada mexicana llegó al puerto de la
habana con alimentos medicinas y oxígeno
este fue el primero de varios envíos de
mexico a la isla que fueron anunciados
el lunes pasado por el presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador y
también llegó a la capital cubana un
avión de la fuerza aérea boliviana con
unas 20 toneladas de ayuda que incluyen
jeringas descartables alimentos e
insumos de bioseguridad las próximas
semanas
masnoticias de américa latina' el
defensor del pueblo de colombia pide un
plan de choque humanitario para lidiar
con la crítica situación que están
viviendo unas 10.000 personas que
continúan varadas en el municipio
colombiano de necoclí al noroeste del
país la reapertura de fronteras tras los
cierres causados por la pandemia de
coronavirus ha hecho que aumente de
manera drástica el flujo de inmigrantes
que tratan de cruzar hacia el norte por
el peligroso estrecho del darién que
separa a colombia y panamá según
migración colombia anualmente se
registra el paso de unas 330 mil
personas nuestra enviada oficial su red
de año nos amplía la información desde
necoclí
es tensa la situación que se vive aquí
en el municipio de necoclí en el
noroccidente de colombia kilómetros de
la frontera con panamá por el gran
represamiento de migrantes que están en
este lugar según las autoridades locales
son entre 10.000 y 15.000 personas las
que estarían aquí a la espera de poder
cruzar hacia el municipio vecino de
capurganá inicialmente se informó que
están represados aquí por las
condiciones meteorológicas que impedían
el cruce vía marítima sin embargo ese
tránsito ya se ha rehabilitado y pasan
entre 800 personas a diario sin embargo
también hay informes de que entran
diariamente hasta necoclí unas mil
personas encontramos aquí ciudadanos
haitianos sobre todo migrantes cubanos
migrantes venezolanos que están buscando
cruzar hacia el norte las autoridades
locales temen que las condiciones y la
gran cantidad de personas que están aquí
aumenten los casos de kobe 19 por lo que
decretaron el estado de calamidad
pública
y avanzamos ahora con algunas noticias
vinculadas al avance de la pandemia de
coronavirus a lo largo del mundo israel
comenzó este viernes a aplicar una
tercera dosis de la vacuna de facer
bayón tech entre sus ciudadanos mayores
de 60 años que hayan recibido la segunda
dosis hace al menos cinco meses esto se
da del medio de los esfuerzos del
gobierno por frenar la propagación de la
variante delta del virus
en chile el 80% de la población
susceptible de ser vacunada completó su
esquema de vacunación contra el cubit 19
según cifras del ministro de salud del
país la autoridad destacó además que
hasta la fecha ya se ha inoculado al 72%
de los jóvenes de entre 15 y 17 años
y al primer contingente de vacunas
donadas por reino unido para ayudar a
combatir la pandemia partió desde
londres el viernes con destino a guyana
belice y otros países este lote de 9
millones es el primer tramo de la
donación de los 100 millones de vacunas
de oxford astrazéneca que serían
enviadas a naciones de bajos recursos
y mientras tanto en organizar una
oficina de las naciones unidas fue
atacada este miércoles en la provincia
de herat los enfrentamientos entre los
talibanes y las fuerzas del gobierno
central se intensificaron desde que las
tropas estadounidenses y de la otan
anunciaron su retiro definitivo que
culminará el próximo 31 de agosto
de intensos combates en la provincia
afgana de herat es una oficina de las
naciones unidas fue blanco de disparos
cuando los talibanes y las fuerzas
gubernamentales se enfrentaban en la
zona una persona murió tras el ataque y
varias resultaron heridas ya que los
ataques contra civiles y el personal de
la onu están prohibidos bajo la ley
internacional y pueden constituir un
crimen de guerra
a medida que las últimas tropas
estadounidenses y la de la otan
completan su retirada que terminará el
31 de agosto los combates se
intensifican los talibanes han capturado
decenas de distritos rurales y se han
apoderado de varios pasos fronterizos
estratégicos las fuerzas afganas por su
parte han opuesto poca resistencia y
ahora solo controlan las capitales de
las provincias
creo que nosotros al igual que todos los
afganos estamos profundamente
preocupados por los acontecimientos que
se han producido en las últimas seis o
siete semanas y por el avance de los
talibanes en una serie de distritos que
antes no controlaban
mientras tanto los ancianos que
trabajaron para el ejército de eeuu
tocaron el jueves del suelo de este país
más de 20 mil afganos solicitaron un
asilo en eeuu por miedo a represalias
avanzamos con más noticias el primero de
agosto los mexicanos están llamados a
las urnas pero no para elegir
gobernantes sino para participar en una
consulta popular que en un principio
buscaba enjuiciar a expresidentes pero
como estos no gozan de inmunidad subiera
delitos no prescritos podrían ser
procesados de todos modos y ante esta
situación la corte del país modificó la
pregunta para que la gente diga así
deben esclarecer las decisiones tomadas
por actores políticos del pasado a fin
de garantizar justicia para las víctimas
y mário carbón el corresponsal de france
24 en ciudad de mexico tiene la historia
43 munición
omar garcía es sobreviviente del caso
ayotzinapa la desaparición de 43
estudiantes con la complicidad de la
policía ha estado viajando para promover
la consulta popular que se hará en
mexico para que la población decida si
se deben esclarecer hechos del pasado y
procurar justicia
todo lo que hemos hecho en el caso de
china para hay otras personas
en otros casos siempre ha sido con el
objetivo de abonar sabemos que una
consulta popular no es definitiva ni
definitoria es un paso más es una forma
de agrietar el muro de la impunidad
la pregunta original impulsada por el
presidente lópez obrador era consultar
si se enjuicia expresidentes aunque de
hecho no tienen inmunidad tras la
polémica la corte cambió la redacción y
la enfocó en el esclarecimiento de
decisiones de actores políticos del
pasado pero la pregunta quedó difusa
y otras víctimas y una parte de la
sociedad no están muy de acuerdo con la
consulta es el caso del poeta y
activista javier sicilia cuyo hijo fue
asesinado
la justicia
no no se pone a discusión la verdad no
se pone a discusión o al parecer de la
gente es la condición del estado la vida
del estado y la exigencia de una nación
defensores de derechos aprovechan el
contexto para señalar que más que
enjuiciar a expresidentes se necesitan
comisiones de la verdad y mecanismos de
justicia transicional detrás de la
pregunta de la consulta está el derecho
a la verdad el derecho a saber que
tenemos todas las personas las víctimas
por supuesto pero la sociedad en general
a saber qué pasó la mayoría de la gente
se quedó con la idea del juicio
expresidentes pero la consulta en sí
divide opiniones y para que sea
repugnante necesitan participar 37
millones de mexicanos es todo por el
momento gracias por acompañarnos pero
como ustedes saben en las noticias no se
detienen así que sigan en france 24 en
france24 punto com
[Música]